i'm jane secker and you're listening to
episode 8
of storycast 21.
in 2016 isis bombers targeted the
belgian capital brussels
killing 32 civilians and injuring more
than
300 people the podcast you're about to
hear is a graphic eyewitness account of
the attack
as it unfolded this is terror
in brussels airport
my name is alex rossi my job title is
national correspondent for sky news
i was at brussels airport on the 22nd of
march 2016.
i was flying to tel aviv back to
my base in jerusalem in israel it is
just over four days since the wave of
coordinated bombings and shootings
i was in brussels to cover the arrest of
salah he was one of the people wanted in
connection
with the paris attacks which
happened five months earlier after raids
across
france and into belgium
i'm jane secker and you're listening to
episode 8
of storycast 21.
in 2016 isis bombers targeted the
belgian capital brussels
killing 32 civilians and injuring more
than
300 people the podcast you're about to
hear is a graphic
eyewitness account of the attack as it
unfolded
this is terror in brussels airport
my name is alex rossi my job title is
national correspondent for sky news
i was at brussels airport on the 22nd of
march 2016.
i was flying to tel aviv back to
my base in jerusalem in israel it is
just over four days since a wave of
coordinated bombings and shootings
i was in brussels to cover the arrest of
salah abdul salam he was one of the
people wanted in connection
with the paris attacks which had
happened five months earlier
after raids across france and into
belgium
now was born
in belgium he came from the mullenbake
area in brussels now that's where the
isis cell
who carried out the paris attacks that's
where they came from
they had thought he was in syria but
intelligence has led police
isis was a terrorist organization
and they had taken a huge swathe of
syria they'd taken a huge swathe
of iraq they wanted to
get all muslims to conform to their view
of what islam was and now they were bent
on
on carrying out attacks in the west as
well
for several hours gunfire grenades and
heavy weapons could be heard
in paris of course 130 people
were killed in a series of coordinated
suicide bombings
and after abdul salam's arrest
it was time really to go back to base in
the middle east
[Music]
it's all a bit of a haze but i think we
must have got to the airport
at around ten past seven that morning
i was with a guy called ariel who was
the
middle east videotape editor and he was
also producing as well
and with a guy called samir who was a
palestinian from east jerusalem and they
were
on assignment with me because of the
additional security
flying to israel they insisted on you
know perhaps getting there three hours
before
and we just um gone through security
i didn't know that at the same time
three terrorists from the isis cell who
were responsible for the paris attacks
had
also entered the airport alongside
hundreds of
passengers many of them commuters some
of them holiday makers
passengers for uh arabia morocco my name
is
sebastian bellen from brussels belgium
uh even though i was born in sao paulo
brazil
i am 42 years old immediately to gate
and b-33
i was flying from the main terminal
terminal one i think in
brussels to new york on american
airlines we are now
closing the gate and uh i was rushing
to the check-in counter
[Music]
at this point we've actually crossed
into duty-free
so we're on the other side of security
the three isis
terrorists
they were walking calmly through the
airport
getting ready to detonate suicide vests
which were packed with nail bombs they
were inside the departure hall
not far away from where we were standing
i quickly checked in and as they were
handing me my
boarding pass
that's when the first bomb went off
about
50 yards behind me
[Music]
the building the fabric of the building
shook
it rocked dust starts coming out
everywhere and
we just sort of hunkered down i mean we
knew it was in the airport
on the check inside
what we didn't know was that one of the
terrorists ibrahim
had just detonated his form
and i just saw you know the ceiling
crashing down just the destruction
my intuition said they were going to
come in and start shooting up
or there'd be another bomb where
everybody was rushing too
so uh i rushed towards the security
check encounters i was you know
zigzagging
people but a second terrorist was going
towards the main exit
i passed him
and he detonated the bomb
and we're still crouched down at this
stage on the far side of the petition
the second terrorist this is nadjim la
crowley
has also detonated his device but at the
opposite end of the hall from the first
explosion
we kind of knew what was happening
but of course at this point we'd no idea
the extent of the carnage
i don't know when i came around the
ringing in my ears
was was just unbearable
and i saw just help around me just
complete hell
dead people and a lot of dust
a lot of debris there was kind of
bones and flesh just kind of sticking
out of my hip
my legs weren't responding and i could
see like holes
into my legs in both legs
i started like trying to slide myself
away from just this horror that was
around
after the second explosion we
stayed where we were sort of crouching
down
trying to assess what was going on and
process what was going on
i spoke to my wife and uh you know
reassured her that we were okay and told
her to
keep the kids away from the the tv
until i could talk to them but i'm
safe samia's safe ariel's safe
and let's just bring you some breaking
news we're hearing uh reports of an
explosion
at brussels airport uh i phoned
through to the news desk in london just
just tell us what's happening and what
those officials are saying to you all
we're we're all being moved out of i
said look i have no doubt in my mind
that the airport has
just come under a terrorist attack we
can't confirm that hasn't been confirmed
by the authorities
um and of course we started recording
and gathering
pictures where we were smoke at brussels
airport terminal after what sounded like
two explosions happening just before
we were doing what we paid to do
with journalists we record things we
chronicle we document
alex and we can see you now on the phone
to us just just tell us
we had to assume really you know many
people were dead
badly injured on the other side of the
security that we've gone through
my biggest fear was that that wasn't the
end of the attack
[Music]
they were evacuating you know dead
people you saw dead people under
blankets
[Music]
and i was i started being dragged and
i'm hanging on to my left leg because i
thought it was detached
so i didn't want to leave my left leg
behind me
in the distance i saw a baggage cart you
know someone brought that over to me
and uh somehow i managed to lift myself
up on the cart
it's getting harder to breathe you're
losing so much blood
so you're like man i'm getting somewhere
but i don't if i'm going to run out of
time
so it's now about half an hour
after the explosions and of course
at this point we didn't know that there
was also a third
bomber we're we're all being moved out
of the airport
now pretty much locked to the phone
doing live broadcasts
and we use the iphones to do a live
broadcast envision
people had two phones and i was using
the other phone so i could hear
the questions from the presenter in the
studio just tell us what's happening and
what those officials are saying to you
all
there are fears so there may be other
attackers
but i think at that time certainly what
we have seen one of the things i
was thinking is that we may be actually
walking into
something far worse uh further along
now as we can see all those passengers
having to leave that terminal building
along with you
talk to us about the security so i um
at that point i'm on the cart and they
pushed me to the back
of the airport and i was kind of furious
i was like no i'll go to the front
they're yelling at me saying no there's
a third bomb
i was like i'm dying you know like i'm
bleeding look and there's already huge
puddles
of blood on the cart
i asked for some water and so the the
young airport worker
comes back with the cup of water
and i i drink it and then i look at him
and i say look just
push me to the front of the airport i
can't state that if i stay
here i'm going to die i can see him
completely tormented
by the idea of you know this guy like
what should i do because everyone's
saying no no you got to stay
and i just say look trust me you know
don't worry
[Music]
and so he just pushes me uh up to the
front
near the elevators and where we can't go
any further because of debris
he just leaves me there just pictures
though coming into us from the scene
at the metro station in brussels where
up to 10 people potentially have died
this is maelbeck
metro station in the eu quarter the
explosion there happened by the time
the bomb went off on the metro that was
what
just uh about an hour afterwards
we're trying to escape we're not
sure what's going on go down go down
so head towards the exit there's
absolute chaos in the airports nobody
really is in control
explosions but we're being ushered
through this area now
uh when you look to the faces of of
people walking through the airport
it was clear that you know they were
really frightened
because we didn't know at this stage
whether or not
there was going to be a further attack
inside the airport
we're slowly getting towards uh safety
trying to
to come out of the airport we're being
shepherded through to where the planes
normally take off but of course
on the other side for people like
sebastian
it was a completely different scene
so they pushed me up to the front near
the elevators
and um and so for a few minutes i'm just
all by myself
you know just wondering well is this a
good decision that i made
and um you know kind of yelling
there's still so much debris everywhere
and dust
and luckily about four firemen
uh turn the corner they pick up the cart
and they they wheel me to outside
[Music]
for the first time like i feel the fresh
air
you know my body's little by little
going into shock i'm sweating
and um kind of an emergency
uh worker comes over to me
tell him i need to get into an ambulance
i i can feel myself going
and the next thing i know is i'm in the
ambulance
and in the ambulance i'm just i'm just
overwhelmed
with uh with emotions i'm like i can't
believe uh
i can't believe i made it
[Music]
we're now being moved out of the
building
uh to to where the planes are parked up
we have been given instructions
if i think through it must have been
at around quarter to ten that we
finally made it to safety we knew that
we were going to be okay
we went down some stairs and ended up on
the apron
of the airport moved through and out at
the moment
we learned later that the third bomber
from the airport this is the man who was
picked up on the closer
television mohamed abrini his bomb
had failed to detonate and he'd fled the
airport
and he was later arrested
in total 32 people were killed
by the three suicide bombs hundreds
were injured but it was only much later
that you hear the stories of people like
sebastian who were in departures
when the attack happened
i've had 13 surgeries since that day
i still had my legs but the whole inside
my leg is all metal
you know i've accepted my my my
disability my permanent disability
but i think it's uh you know i'm
actually
very lucky to have been so close to
death
those other victims me as a survivor i i
carry them with me
um with with so much gratefulness that
i'm not one of them
and and that gratefulness is something
that um
has has has created a lot of positive
energy
in me
[Music]
i've had quite a few close calls over
the years
moments you know if you'd arrived
moments earlier
or left moments later
you things would be very different
i find it hard to think about it without
thinking about luck
really luck
is all there is sometimes
[Music]
terror in brussels airport was recorded
by tom gillespie
writing and production by rob mulhern
for more information on this story log
on to skynews.com forward slash
storycast 21
next time two rival biker gangs go to
war
in the uk midlands
members of both groups had found
themselves on the same flight
back into birmingham from alicante
they both made calls to their people on
the ground in the midlands to tell them
to meet them when they landed at the
airport
in total 30 bikers assembled in the
arrivals hall at birmingham airport and
started attacking each other
[Music]
you